hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hello neighbor now this
game is in early alpha which means that
if it glitches out and dies and it's
funny
heck yeah keep it in the game but if
it's bad don't blame it don't blame me
don't blame
hi that is the loudest ambiance I've
ever heard in my life and I grew up in
the Midwest Oh am i oh [ __ ] am I
supposed to go over there or am I
supposed to turn out the light so they
don't see me hello also why is my bed on
display for the entire neighborhood to
see okay Oh my house is tiny oh wait a
minute how do I get to the rest of my
house hello okay all right this is
nothing oh my god the grasshoppers are
like digging needles into my ears can I
get out of this I mean no wonder I go to
my neighbor's house I don't want to hear
this [ __ ] hello Jesus well I mean that's
better ambience and what I was having to
deal with over there ooh
something tells me this ain't gonna be
too friendly a visit oh wow
ah
Maybury no neighbor waiver what the heck
is this err why do you have cameras in
there hey the [ __ ] was that okay well
I'm a little confessor
I don't know what the hell's going on
[ __ ] you what the [ __ ] has happened who
the hell is that okay fine then I'm
bolting over there [ __ ] you you think
you can stop me at least freaking things
aren't chirping anymore okay alrighty
then [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you need to
stop that I'm just trying to get into
this [ __ ] no no I called it a [ __ ]
it's a lovely lovely game oh god get it
out of here
gotta run got a run for it got a run for
it no you don't see that hello
where the heck are you do I have a
flashlight do I have any means of
Defence can i grab like these old used
food boxes and bash them upside the head
a broom okay
all righty then well that's nice okay oh
I thought they were kissing they're just
staring alrighty then
well that's that's lovely I can't see
[ __ ] okay all the doors are locked
except front one oh the camera
that's what beeped he can freakin see me
oh boy oh god it's a bright sunshiny day
maybe I shouldn't go over to my
neighbor's house maybe I should hold hey
hi say you know that's a potted plant
I'm a goddamn fool that's why I'm
laughing over here Bing bong
okay nevermind oh he smarted up he
actually locked his damn door okay
alrighty then I have no idea I'm very
confused well this doesn't seem right
[Music]
who's doing it
hi neighbor may I come in okay can I get
over here maybe oh just a little bit yes
Oh side door no okay that's not gonna
work neighbor ding damn it
oh well that seems a little less than
friendly okay [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm not ready
for this oh god it's so shiny out oh
what a lovely beautiful day okay I'm
sure glad it's still the wood stepping
sound effects as I go through the day
why'd you put it on your front door it's
okay hello neighbor I know you want your
privacy and everything and I think I saw
you moving around in your window there
but I'm
Oh God methinks we got away by just the
skin of my balls
I suppose that seems like pretty frantic
steps towards me oh no oh he's upstairs
okay
please hope use you better not become
familiar oh god damn it I need to stop
hitting those I hit the use button on
him because I think it's gonna like you
know okay well now this is open I guess
that's good question mark well so what
is with that okay I didn't know what was
going on with me but uh already then I
see them walking around in there how do
I get to the upstairs
can't I get to the officer what's the
point of me going over there good a
bastard of a neighbor and I could have a
douchenozzle neighbor goes over and just
barge into his friend's house not even
saying hello or hi god I got let me in
I'm being driven insane by the sounds I
got a command please sir
I rang the doorbell like a polite person
he's gonna straight-up murder me
Oh neighbor hidey-ho neighbor neighbor
II know you'll never know that it was
actually me dingdong ditching you what a
doofus guy okay alrighty then why hi
you're outside your house now hello ah
good big Morgan neighbor II know but I
didn't know you could do that neighbor
[Music]
he threw it at what oh he's laying out
the traps okay that explains it okay so
he's he's actually laying out ribs I
mean after a while wouldn't you get so
paranoid that your neighbor constantly
endlessly just starts barging into your
house you you might set up counter
measures as well okay yeah you go in
there I'm gonna go in here MA yeah
that's more like it
okay so I got to figure out how to open
this
I mean I don't know that's not good oh
damn it I walked up so you throw
tomatoes at my house [ __ ] you you know
you're real mature Oh real mature
hey real real mature okay real mature
neighborhood neighbor neighbor II know
and if this game just a bag of dicks and
ain't you just a bag of dicks everything
about this is a bag of dicks oh this is
bad it's bad what's that it doesn't work
oh it does work it does I don't know why
it works that worked okay what did that
accomplish me I don't know what's with
this upside-down room but it exists all
right where is this does this have
anything to do with how to get past this
douche no it does not this is no reason
to be in here this doesn't work okay
goodbye
there's another door up there
ah that didn't help anybody this is the
opposite of good I don't think there's
any way to win this where is hey hey hey
buddy
hey neighbor howdy ho neighbor Reno hey
diddly ho go [ __ ] yourself huh how about
that
oh [ __ ] I shouldn't be in there oh this
is not good
there's nothing in here oh there's
nothing it's literally a broom closet
with a trap in it ah he could come in
here at any moment
what the hell are these light bulbs oh
boy I've [ __ ] maybe I could trap him
by one of his own traps is I think that
can happen I don't think so
I'm for worked oh [ __ ] all right okay
okay big ol hug in the middle of the
road okay but anyway that is hello
neighbor this is in very early acces so
there's almost no fully fleshed out
features left but this game does look
promising it's actually legitimately
scary when you're in there and I have no
idea where he is so I like it a lot
being stalked around someone else's
house and not knowing why you're in
their house also why was he big I have
no idea but either way there's a fun
game
you can't play just yeah this is an
early access demo that was given to by
the developer so hopefully very soon
there'll be something that you guys can
play so thank you again everybody for
watching let me know he thought down the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video god damnit you
dick
[Music]